[Music]
let's get into Star Wars I'm sure that's
why most people here battlefront 2
finally after that leaked teaser trailer
that if that teacher trailer we know
much more about it Kelly plague you were
down at Star Wars Celebration in Orlando
last week I was and you talked to some
of the writers of the story mode which
we saw the trailer for the last trailer
focus more on the campaign which the
first game was lacking and I think a lot
of people are excited to see that so i
did want to start with story mode and
what they're doing with it what we kind
of discerned from the trailer last week
we already talked about that but between
i guess all four of us we have
especially youtube we had a lot of Star
Wars knowledge it on the set today so I
want to talk about what are your kind of
impressions of story about so far what's
going on with it um okay so basically
I'm really excited for it because it's
kind of switching perspectives it's
about an imperial commander named I
denver CO and so you're kind of that
they're they're taking great measures to
do not portray it as like this black and
white good versus evil thing necessarily
it's it's they're not betraying the
Empire's bad guys you really are a
protagonist in this game from what I
understand and I think that's really
interesting and you get to kind of see
what the Empire of uses heroism with
regard to like order and stability is
very much an imperial thing and it takes
place right after the events of Return
of the Jedi so it's picking up in the 30
years between that movie and force
awakens so it's kind of exploring this
timeline that we know Freddie not a lot
about I'm not mainstream right yeah it's
not mainstream for sure I mean like they
talked about the writers talked about
being inspired by aftermath and the
shattered Empire comics which I thought
was really cool so there's there's stuff
in the existing cannon that that you can
kind of base this off of but they're
really trying to explore something that
Star Wars hasn't really done yet so I'm
really looking forward to it and it
sounds like um you know it's like an
elite squad it's called the inferno
squadron is what she's part of and their
pilots but also good boots on the ground
sort of soldiers and yeah I'm excited
yeah Rob you looked you spent most of
like yesterday afternoon kind of looking
into the lore of this
can you enlighten us as to what might be
going on plot-wise yeah so you know
we've talked about this bunch of times
and it's yeah it's as Callie said like
it's filling in a nice gap that has been
untold for the most part but yeah I
started hitting up the Wikipedia
Wikipedia but those exiting said it
early no it's that's legit got a hacker
ecovillage karaoke village that's a joke
okay and yeah I got lost in that stuff
and I have some notes on what I think
we'll be seeing so John look if you
wanna roll that b roll you might want to
like jump around a little bit but um
yeah essentially you VI we play this
character I didn't write so we're gonna
see this trailer if he yeah I probably
should have trimmed this a little bit
but regardless so there you have already
shots of force awakens um yeah you just
keep moving along dart killer bass or
just play this John Luke I think I timed
it so that's that droid again it's a
secret droid that you you can imagine is
like a companion yeah and they said in
the presentation that I went to that the
droid is going to kind of be a big part
of gameplay mmhmm yeah you actually see
a little bit of an action it's an ID 9
like secret droid and it can walk and
talk in person eight other droid so I
think there's just an arsenal of
abilities that can have that you'll
probably be seeing I wonder if it'll
kind of play the part of like I don't
know detective vision that's in so many
games now like what was it what was that
a thing that a law used in horizon focus
ya know anyway sorry so this ship on you
know we have really seen this before but
I looked it up and it's um so I believe
it's a Raider class corvette which
essentially uh is tasked with like
taking down rebel 10-run ships so it's
like an it's like an anti a cruiser for
the rebel lines so it's like quick and
it's got like a single turbo laser like
compared to like it a star shore has
like multiple series of turbolasers so
Scott some weapons on it so you can I
would definitely imagine you're flying
this thing and some space battles in the
single-player campaign if you keep going
oh and top right there that
and this was weird pausing it that's a
Mon Calamari cruiser and this clearly
seems to be not a fight our battle scene
so I don't know what the hell that
thing's doing it really GU doing here in
the fleet yeah I mean no one's like
attacking it like maybe it's like
captured and beginning because this is
again Death Star to so and there's no
conflict right now so it's kind of
interesting maybe no one sees it sure
superstars Troy there obviously you
remember from the return of jedi movie
maybe there's some action there with
that thing i believe in the description
of multiplayer you the space battles
will have like takedowns of massive
enemy cruisers so maybe there's some of
that going on space battles and
multiplayer or even single player and
again there's the I the droid again you
see it actually shocking a rebel trooper
here's the wreckage there yeah so this
is if you keep going this is where it
gets really interesting so here's post
Jedi right everyone's bolting so what I
was looking up and again this was in
shattered calm a shattered Empire I'll
back that actually shot to keep playing
John Liu but that's actually a tack of
Donna from force awakens but those are
actually original trilogy Tie Fighters
pose a new first order TIE fighters just
really weird that they're going back to
that planet so this is the coolest stuff
right here so that guy it's like who is
this dude he is a sentinel and in the
shattered Empire comics he after the
Empire died he or the Emperor died he
realized he needs to basically have a
wheel if I die I need to have these
command so he has these droids that's
like a like a dressed-up you know Royal
Guard droid there that will deliver his
final commands and this is all lore
there's something called the contingency
which is basically when he goes with
Denver says if I die destroy the Empire
and he has these guys carry out orders
so he's been telling her more most
likely like this is now my next plan
here he is in the comics um he would do
things like he had a prong so he would
pierce your skin and get like a blood
sample and see if you're actually legit
who you were toy before he like relayed
the plans essentially as one does is all
you call them prongs prongs needles I
was joking now so he's got the face of
the Emperor on him and one of his first
plants or after and/or battled endured
his first plan was the battle of naboo
so he had the Emperor as you know from
the prequels was born on that planet is
a center from that planet the Emperor
wanted to basically erase all ties of
him being a sip so he had basically the
the the Empire go displaying a tacit use
these satellites to create hurricanes on
the planet flood the capital of Naboo
which is feed which evidently is a map
in this game they say at the bottom feed
is something you'll play in multiplayer
and have his staff basically throw and
destroy all the SIF like relics that he
had and then with the final stages of
his contingency plan was to at some
point eliminate all officers other than
like a few higher ups and have those
officers then flee to the outer rim one
of them being forgot his first name but
actually about that down was his name I
did not but it's early first order to
start the first order and one of them
being Huck's his son is the Admiral
Huck's that you know from the force
awakens so that's super neat like yeah
you're gonna see bit you're gonna see
the start of the first order and whether
or not she's a part of it we'll have to
see ya when I talked to them there they
worked very closely with Lucasfilm to
make sure this is all you know it fits
into the continuity they don't like
using the term canon but that's like the
easiest way to describe it but like
they've created a new planet and they
are they really they're focusing on
exploring what happens to the Empire
after the Emperor and so a lot of that
from shattered Empire kind of coincides
with what they were saying so yeah I'd
say that's pretty spot-on yeah you're
talking to us you're talking to some of
the writers right Mitch Dyer used to be
at IGN but now he's working here on this
game yes so and while William full
disclosure I used to work with Mitch
Dyer at IGN but he's working on this
game now with motive studios
and I was getting a lot of rogue one
vibes from just the tone and what they
were saying about the game and it seems
like for them rogue one kind of
validated what they were already doing
with this story so I would imagine it's
going to be totally at least a little
bit more in that vein than then maybe
you know what you're used to with the
original trilogy at least or even you
know force awakens kind of like focus
more on one squad a la banda brothers
Saving Private Ryan or even nine it's
interesting to see like rumors about the
next Call of Duty going back to World
War 2 yet some wonder like maybe people
are focusing more I mean it says like
the untold soldier story but it's
interesting to see where it go
especially cuz Walt Williams wrote
helped write spec ops the line right so
the other writer yeah he he wrote spec
ops the line so I'm very interested to
see what the way where this story goes
and what tactic they take with it yeah
you want to be fun especially because
its first single player campaign since
battlefront 2 which had like galactic
conquest and that those story modes
which were kind of they were the
campaigns for all four factions but it
would still be interesting to see things
from the Empire's perspective especially
after it's just shattered you mentioned
Halo Reach is a comparison like you know
things won't end well but you still kind
of enjoy the ride while you're playing
it yeah so I'm here to see where it goes
especially after those the lawyer you're
talking about when you were talking to
the writers down in Orlando last week
cool let us know what you think if you
notice anything the trailer that we
didn't if you have read aftermath or a
shattered Empire let us know if you have
any theories about what we might see in
Bal front 2 and releases november
seventeenth of this yes and be sure to
check out our everything we know so far
if you have any questions lays out
basically the story and kind of what the
details are yeah and I know John Luke is
working on one of his like history of
pieces of doing a history of battlefront
think that'll be up maybe this weekend
maybe next week we're not positive yet
but you should check that out if you
haven't played a battle front or if you
haven't played in a while you kind of
want get back into it
you
[Music]